Now, let me come back to lists.
Let's go all the way back up to the list. I'm gonna
comment this section and type section
this section two will come back to this.
here
Let's look at the first example we talked about.
How can we add something to a list?
Now there's something need to know about this, right?
These are data structures.
That typically accept incoming data
at the end.
Now, of course, you can add an element to the start or somewhere
in the middle.
But doing that adding the element in the
middle of a list is computationally more expensive.
We'll talk about that that stuff later on once we
get once we go deeper into the data structures.
But typically when you add an element to the end of it, typically you
would add an element to the end of the list. How do we do that? How do we do? How do
we achieve this in Python?
Well, like I said and a list.
Is an instance of a class there's a class called list.
So the people who created the Python program
language created a class.
list
And so whenever you create.
Whenever you write code like this your instantiating a
class.
and since the class
it has a methods.
And how do we see? How do we
go about?
Using a method we use dot syntax. So lists
have methods.
for mutating
for being mutated
so methods like
append
remember method was always be preceded by
a DOT methods like insert.
methods like pop
remove
okay. Typically you want to use a pen. This is the least computational expensive
appendages appended at the end.
Or as insert is used if you want to add an
element to a specific location. This is something you want to use in frequently.
only when necessary
remove
Now pop, we'll remove an element from the end of
the list.
But it can also be used to remove an element from
a specific location. So this is do a purpose
if you if you don't pass any arguments to it, it
will just remove from whatever's at the end. If you put an argument, it
will remove an album from that specific position.
Remove is used when you do not know the position
of the element, but you know, it's a value.
Okay, so let's say you have products over here.
Or let's do brands.
and you're doing some data in you know, you're doing
some data munching for your
data science project
and let's say you no longer you want
to remove a particular brand from the list.
Okay.
And if you do not
know the position for some reason you can use brands that remove.
and whether the nice things about vs code is I will
tell you what
the data type of the parameter
the data type of the parameter. So this one except this expected string
if I were to put your pop.
It says index give me the index of the element so
something new numerical.
but remove
is when you do not know the position.
So Nokia can be anywhere but we'll find
it. Again. This is
computationally expensive
why if you remember on Sunday we talked about Big O
we talked about a very briefly, but we'll go into detail to
be called later on but
We said that.
If you do not know the position of an element.
Then you have to switch the we have to search the entire
data structure for that particular value. So
now here no key is only the third element. That's not so bad. But
imagine we had I don't know.
This was separated by $10,000
elements and Nokia was at the end.
Well in order for python to find the location of that element,
it has to go through the entire list you don't have to do
it, but the computer will have to
okay.
It's easy to add if you want add something to.
If you want to add something to the end of a list.
It's pretty straightforward but searching not so much
which is why we want to talk. We want to explore other data structures.